well you know when you first come onto
campus reunion weekend it really has
this building up coming home and your
walk in through the gates 116th street
and and it's just this wonderful feeling
you just remember all people you knew
and then you start to see the people you
knew that's really fantastic there's a
shared experience that we all have is
alumni when you come back as an alumni
you want to see people you want to
experience the college but it's also a
lot about the personal connections that
we have and seeing people that you don't
always have an opportunity to see
haven't been back to campus in 10 years
but it looks great and I'm having a good
time reliving the college days staying
in carman hall and seeing old friends
and acquaintances I really like class
dinners because it's an occasion when
you get to come together with everyone
hear their stories where they've been
what they've gone through and how we all
started from the same place
I think what's really exciting is to
reconnect with other people I knew in a
more meaningful way at Colombian to see
what everybody is doing they're really
smart interesting diverse different
people a lot of friends I haven't seen
in 20 years sometimes you don't
recognize the names but you always know
the facebook
the community is unique and what I like
about it is that even though I'm not I
wasn't here with a class of nineteen
sixty one we have a lot in common it's
been really fun there's definitely a
really unique conical get sued I think
today is a great day because you get to
be outside they've got great weather you
get to see everybody's kids I think it's
really nice because they do the family
friendly event they seem happy and I'm
kind of giddy that I've got a little
time to actually talk and that my kids
are having fun and someone else's
problem for a bit
it's great we live very far away of salt
lake city utah he lives in California so
it took a special reunion bring us
together
incorporating Dean's they into reunion
we jen has really been fantastic because
you know it it not only gives you the
chance to have people come and see each
other again but to sort of really
reintegrate into the intellectual
process I hadn't been to one of these in
the years past so I thought since I'm in
New York in the summertime might as well
come re-engage with the campus earlier
today I went to a lecture we studied the
core curriculum and I don't think that
other universities that have anything
like it's something that finds the
generations that really helps build a
unity when we talk to folks in our
grandfather class where I talk to
freshmen now when I do alumni
volunteering the fact that we have
shared experiences makes us even prouder
to be Columbia and really makes us even
more family I mean I haven't said take
me to 116th and broadway in so long and
you need it may be lad to say
that was really great to catch up a lot
of people you know migrated across the
country and you have really seen since
graduation living in the door was in
being an arm and freshman year and all
the dumb things we did when we thought
we were so mature in New York I thought
that you had to wear black pants on so
downtown
I think the best thing happening at
Columbia is what's always happened at
Columbia is that it's an amazing
intellectual and academic experience
that has never changed and I think that
has been the really strong foundation
that has always carried us through when
we talk about the alumni experience and
engaging alumni that's all just on top
of everything that Columbia gave us
during those four years when we were
here
you